wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some amazing
motivation from the one and only tom
billion
everyone takes the limits of their own
vision for the limits of the world
arthur schopenhauer
[Music]
there is all around you right now
the reflections of your world belief
they're so ever present that you don't
even see them all the assumption that
you've made about the world the things
that are possible what you're capable of
who you are the very definition of what
it means to be alive
all of it is completely invisible and
you're mistaking what you have
for what could be
and once you break free of that once you
understand that right now you're a
moment in time and that you have latent
potential and that latent potential can
be expressed in the form of skills that
you can get good at things that you can
develop yourself in any direction that
brain plasticity alone
[Music]
is one of the greatest weapons that
you're not using but you have to move
beyond what you can perceive today you
have to begin to look beyond that and
see that which doesn't yet exist
and you have to remember
that many of the things that are holding
you down are rules that you don't even
realize are rules and as general douglas
macarthur said you're remembered for the
rules you break
and right now
you're following rules that you don't
even realize exist and some of those
rules are simply what is okay to dream
but i'm here to tell you the power
is in recognizing
that you can do it the power isn't
having the arrogance of belief the power
is an understanding that you yes you are
going to be capable of something simply
because you're willing to believe in
yourself and that's the thing it's a
willingness to believe in yourself no
one's going to give it to you even the
people that love you they're not going
to give you that they are incapable of
giving it to you people cannot see past
their limitations and they take them for
truth people actually believe the things
that have stopped them will forever not
only stop them but they will stop other
people how can they hope to give you
anything but limitation
so if you know that if you know that
even the people that love you what
they're handing you is limitation with
the best of [ __ ] intentions with all
the love in the world
how are you going to break out of that
how are you going to break past those
rules how are you going to fight the
anxiety that inevitably comes your way
when you think about going against the
grain but my friends until you can do
that you can never get beyond the
[ __ ] that limits you if people said
gravity is what it is we never would
have reached escape velocity and yet as
a species we have been able to hurl a
[ __ ] rocket into space get it outside
of gravity take us to other planets that
is real only because somebody said i
refuse to be held down by the most
obvious rule that we have
the one that everybody says is beyond
reproach and that is gravity
but even gravity will break under the
weight of a superior will so recognize
as epitidus said
if you want to improve be content to be
thought foolish and
stupid can you be content
to be thought foolish and stupid
or do you allow yourself to be caged to
be hemmed in by what other people think
and look i get it i understand the sting
of contempt i understand how much it
sucks when someone you respect doesn't
respect you
but you cannot be anything more than
their captive if you think about what
they think about you if you let yourself
be defined by what other people perceive
of as you then you will forever be
limited by what they give you permission
to do
and i don't know about you but when i
was a kid i said when i'm an adult i
will never [ __ ] be told what to do
again i will never be held back by
somebody else i will define myself i
will figure out what i need to do and i
will do it and at the end of the day
that is it my goals drive my behavior i
am not held back by what other people
think about me no matter how [ __ ]
intoxicating it is to be loved
you have to decide what you want more do
you want to be you or do you want to be
someone else's reflection of you as
daniel ping said
people fail to achieve mastery
not because they aren't talented
but because they aren't disciplined
the wonderful news about the human
condition is you can get good at
anything that you set your mind to it's
just not going to be easy and it's not
going to be fast
but the willingness to put in that work
is what's going to separate you from
everybody else and i'm begging you to
see yourself right now today as
average
as no better than anyone else
but i beg you with more force then i
know how to convey with this language to
see yourself as malleable to see
yourself as capable of becoming anything
you want to become to become truly
extraordinary if you can find within
yourself the discipline to stick with it
long enough and as steve martin said
perseverance
is a great substitute for talent
everybody wants to talk about who's
talented everybody looks at the person
with innate talent as if they have
something magical
but to me
it's a gift it's a handout
it's a freebie it hasn't been earned
and no matter what it is it's only the
beginning even somebody that has talent
even if you get an early win if you let
somebody outwork you if you let somebody
who has more perseverance more grit than
you than they are going to outperform
you on a long enough timeline the only
thing i can guarantee is you will be
outworked by somebody unless you pour
your heart and soul into getting great
if you don't take days off if you put
yourself into it as if your life
depended on it when you act like that
then you've got a chance to be great
and as robert horey said pressure can
bust pipes
but it can also make diamonds
you've got to want that pressure you've
got to want things to be hard you can't
seek out the easy life you can't just
hope and pray that you can uncover
inside of you some talent that's laid
dormant that you didn't know about
that's gonna let things be easy for you
don't want the easy want the hard want
the pressure want the thing that's gonna
turn you into something
because when it's easy
you don't work for it
when it's easy you don't push when it's
easy you get surpassed by the person who
has to give it their all who's prepared
to do blood sweat and tears in order to
become that thing that they want to be
so badly because they are so
angry that they were never given
anything and with that chip on their
shoulder they're determined to become
anything that they set their mind to
so whether you have talent
whether you don't
the only thing that matters is will you
persevere
will you stick with it long enough to
get great
you do not need to think that you are
anything special it is absolutely okay
for you to be hopelessly
average
why
to me the most
powerful thing that you could believe
about yourself is that you're the
average human now why i actually think
it is less powerful for you to think
that you are above average because to
think that you are above average means
that you are valuing yourself for being
better than people it's a super
vulnerable position to be in because you
will inevitably meet people who are
better than you and what do you do with
your ego then then it's really crushing
you thought you were the man and now you
encounter somebody that's better than
you they slap you around they outperform
you they dunk on you whatever and now
whoa like you've got to rebuild and claw
your way back
versus
saying the following
the average human is the ultimate
adaptation machine
as a species
humans have chosen
to respond to cultural and environmental
cues so we do not come pre-programmed
like a horse that comes out of the womb
10 minutes later it's ready to rock and
roll it's running around doing all the
things that a horse can do a human on
the other hand has this huge period of
development after birth where we cannot
take care of ourselves we can't walk
can't hold our own head up we [ __ ] in
our pants it's crazy
but
what that does is it allows us to drink
in this the environment that we're born
into and adapt
so the average human is the ultimate
adaptation machine therefore being the
average human means you're a learner
that's it you're not exceptional so
you're not putting any of your
psychology your
self-worth your pride into being better
than somebody else it all comes down to
valuing yourself for being the learner
so hey cool you wasted a bunch of time
at school no reason to hide from that it
was a waste we're not going to repeat
the mistake but we learn so you've got
the self-awareness to see that it was a
mistake now it's just like what do you
want to do what do you want to get great
at because if you apply yourself even if
you're not good yet
you can get good
how do i know that because you're the
average human and the average human is
the ultimate adaptation machine this is
all about disciplined
focused energy
into acquiring a skill set it's what i
call the only belief that matters when
you believe the time and energy directed
at something through deliberate practice
will actually make you better at that
thing
now all of a sudden it's like i can get
good at anything if i apply myself and
now all of a sudden your behaviors align
with your belief
that's why that belief matters so much
because if you don't think you can get
better at something then why would you
apply any time and energy to it and if
you don't apply time and energy to it
then you really won't get any better
so it becomes this loop of well i
believe i can get better therefore i try
therefore i actually get better
therefore i try harder and you get in
this virtuous cycle
this is hugely important
that is one of those things that will
govern the rest of your life you value
yourself for learning
getting better at something and applying
yourself everything else will take care
of itself because you just keep applying
yourself don't make excuses don't be
asked yourself if you wasted time you
wasted time don't spend your time
beating yourself up over it because we
only do and believe that which moves us
towards our goals rules are i think
underutilized in people's lives and
this is something that i use on a daily
basis
and the rules that i have laid out in my
life
allow me to stay on track so for
instance you have a problem in the
morning of facing an inadequacy okay so
you know something about yourself
that
you're
you like the out of thinking that you
don't have time so that you don't have
to face i set a goal i gave that goal a
deadline and i missed that deadline and
that means punch line of punchlines that
i'm not good enough
which is true if you add the modifier
yet i'm not good enough yet now the
thing that's going to let you off the
hook and allow us to slot in some rules
because you're not fighting against
yourself you're now working for yourself
to achieve the things you want to
achieve is to understand you actually
can get good so it's what i call the
only belief that matters the only belief
that matters
is that
if you put time and attention
into getting better at something you'll
actually get better at it not because
you're special not because you're
brighter than the next person because
that
is the physics of the human mind
that's just how the mind works
the truth of being a human is that if
you apply energy into practicing
something and that practice is well done
you will as an inevitable consequence of
that time and energy have a deeper skill
set that skill set has utility it lets
you do something in the world that other
people cannot do
okay so if we know that's true now we
don't need to seek a distraction because
when we realize oh we're not good enough
yet all that does another layer of
self-awareness it lets us know the thing
that we need to get better at and now if
i apply my time and energy to that thing
i will actually improve so okay cool now
i need rules to make sure that i clear
that space for me to actually get good
at that thing now the only catch there
is it needs to be something that you're
actually excited to get good at right
like imagine that world where you're
truly world class at that thing right
the only thing that stands between you
and being world class at anything you
care about maybe not the best in the
world but world class
is time and so if you like that thing
you're excited by that thing then you
put these rules and so a simple rule may
be
i don't check my phone under any
circumstance for any reason before 10 am
i don't know what your rule is going to
be it depends on what time you wake up
but for me i don't take meetings before
10 a.m the way i say it to myself is i
don't let anyone control my time before
10 am i don't take meetings from
anybody on the team at impact theory i
don't even take meetings with lisa
unless there's something really
like high
time pressure that needs to be dealt
with as nelson mandela said
education
is the most powerful weapon you can use
to change the world
wherever you are right now listening to
this i want you to burn that into your
mind the most powerful weapon that
you're going to have at your disposal
isn't a gun it isn't a sword it isn't a
bomb the most powerful weapon you will
ever have at your disposal if you really
want to make change
is knowledge
it doesn't mean going to school it can
be school it can be books it can be a
mentor it can be somebody else's failure
it can be your own
failure
but whatever it is to always be learning
to be learning something today knowing
that that's an investment and as robert
louis stevenson said don't judge each
day by the harvest you reap
but rather by the seeds you plant
and that's what knowledge is that's what
the learning process is is you're
learning something today that you may
not even understand how it's going to be
valuable
but one day
piece of knowledge is going to come to
your aid one day that thing that you
learned is going to be something that
you're going to lean on one day that
thing that you've worked your ass off to
understand better than anybody else in
the world
it's going to help you change
the world
but you have to be doing it now you have
to be learning with an obsession you
have to understand that ideas in equal
ideas out and that you have to chase
that knowledge down that it is a
relentless pursuit and that like you
would build an armada like you would
create a stock pile of weapons you must
create a stockpile of knowledge you must
learn and learn and learn and you must
hold yourself accountable every day to
planning those seeds to getting better
to learning more to understanding things
more broadly when you do that there will
be nothing that won't be unlocked to you
that's what i want you guys to
understand it doesn't matter where you
are now it doesn't matter where you
started your circumstances the money the
people that you know none of it matters
what matters is how much you willing to
learn how good are you willing to get
how much knowledge are you willing to
soak in because that
will become your weapon that will be how
you rise up and that will be the thing
that will protect you when you need it
most what tools can i use to help shut
off my brain from the millions of ideas
when i've chosen one to give all my
energy and focus to i left my job as vp
of a major food company after 10 years a
year ago to start my own business and i
struggle with being my own boss now that
i only have myself to hold myself
accountable but this business is my
livelihood and my future and my passion
project all right i love this man i can
relate to this heavily all right i've
always said that the thing that sobers
up entrepreneurs faster than anything is
to have your house on the line when
you've got a wife kids just rent to make
whatever even if you're a solo flyer but
you know you've got to eat all of a
sudden you become real sober about
either something is working or it is not
and when it is not working man you
better make a change and make a change
asap there's some real clarity to that
now i would say that you want
and i can predict the the kickback i'm
going to get on this but this is the
[ __ ] truth and because i live it
every day as 50 cent said i came in the
game humble can't nobody tell me [ __ ]
now
you want to tie your identity to your
success it's [ __ ] dangerous because
oh my god if you end up failing you're
going to have to backtrack real fast and
get your identity back out of that but
we're going to save that for another
class for now i'm going to tell you hey
the fact that it's all writing on the
line the fact that you said you were
going to do this and now baby it's put
up or shut up
let that ride on you now be very careful
don't let it create so much pressure
that you become paralyzed because that
does not serve you we do and believe
that which moves us towards our goals so
we want the pressure but not so much
that it causes us to crack not so much
that it slows us down or
um you know puts us in this death spiral
right
you never allow yourself to say the
words i'm out of moves you're never out
of moves you're never out of options
right there is always something else
that you can do number one rule of being
an entrepreneur avoid a mortality event
the name of the game is to stay in
business long enough to figure it out it
is very okay to not know what you're
doing right now it is very much not okay
to stand still the only wrong move in
life ever is standing still indecision
will kill you mistakes will not
now we can get into the idea of dent the
car don't total the car because of
course yes you could make a fatal
mistake but those are usually pretty
easy to spot if you ask yourself hey if
this fails do i go out of business if
the answer is yes don't even attempt it
move on to something where the answer is
no far better to take incremental steps
towards your goal to stay in the game
long enough to figure out exactly what
direction you want to be taking those
steps in then to do one sort of big put
it all on the roulette wheel embed it
all on black okay that we do not want to
do
stay in the game
tie your identity to that success be all
in
while i don't encourage people to burn
the ships of the shore i actually
encourage people keep your day job
you've already burned your ships to the
shore so you need to be honest that
behind you is the flaming wreckage of
your previous life now probably good to
hold a little nugget in your head
reminding you that you can always get
back to that because you have the skills
and skills have utility but for now
we're going to close the door on that
that that's going to be the break clap
break glass in case of emergency sort of
notion for now we want to make sure that
since we left our previous job it's do
or die so let's do now personally i
respond well to that i love that i love
having things right on it
but i'm very careful not to let that
overwhelm me so
the whole notion of overwhelm is outside
the scope of this question but i think
you're in a powerful position
but you have to embrace the do or die
mentality so get in there get after it
as frederic nietzsche said
many are stubborn in pursuit of the path
they have chosen
few
in pursuit of the goal
and that's one of the things that really
trips people up
at the end of the day a path is an
option it's one of the ways forward but
it's the thing that you're doing right
now today so people get
really focused on that they make their
happiness built around that they think
about that as the thing
but as the old saying goes
don't confuse the finger
with the moon that it's pointing at
that's where you've got to be really
careful at the end of the day the goal
is the thing that you're trying to
achieve the goal is what you're trying
to get
the path is irrelevant the path is
really your best guess it's the thing
you think is going to work but if you
become myopically focused on that if you
think that the path really is the end
thing if you think the finger actually
is
the moon
then you miss the objective to which
you're fighting for then you're not
going to have the energy to keep pushing
when things get really hard because
you're going to have mistaken
the way of getting there with the
destination itself and i think that
people a lot of times throw hate on
having a destination on
building towards some big goal of having
some grand thing that they're chasing
but as einstein said if you want to live
a happy life
tie it to a goal
not to people
not to things
and the reason that he said that people
and things they change you've got no
control over them at the end of the day
the only thing you really control is
yourself at the end of the day the only
thing that you can hope for
is to be going after something that has
meaning
something that has purpose something
that really gives you a reason for being
that directs your actions that becomes
the filter by which you judge everything
that really becomes the center of the
gravitational center of your own
universe
but it's the goal
not the path
so what is it that you really want you
have to identify that to me everything
in life
everything in life starts with the goal
and you work your way backwards don't
allow yourself to get caught up in other
people and putting your happiness in
somebody else and finding purpose in
something else and trying to obtain
things
have it be something that you're trying
to accomplish have it be something that
you're trying to become
once you're on the path to becoming
then you can find
real
happiness
some things you
build whether you can control the
outcome or not sometimes it's the
process
that is the thing that's meant to be
enjoyed it's the process that you're
meant to invest in and rather than
always thinking about the goal the
outcome or what you're going to get out
of something
focus on the something focus on the part
of it that you can control because you
can't always control the outcome you
can't know what's going to happen
tomorrow tomorrow's not guaranteed to
any of us
and yet we all act and yet we create
momentum in our lives when we're at our
best
but we do that not because we can
control every aspect we do that because
we accept that there are things that we
cannot control
and as steve maraboli said
incredible change happens in your life
when you decide to take control of what
you do have power over
instead of craving control over what you
don't
and that's where a lot of people get
lost
they focus not on what they have in
their hands they focus instead on the
things that they can't control it
irritates them it frustrates them it's
like a splinter in their mind they can't
stop thinking about the things that they
don't have control over and they're
blinded to the incredible wealth that is
around them of things that they could
enjoy right here
right
now
that's why gratitude is such an
empowering practice to sit there and not
think of the glorious things may await
you in your future but rather to think
about the things you have here in this
moment oxygen in your lungs a simple
breeze on your face a window in your
house someone that you love someone that
loves you
nothing that costs money nothing that
was the pot of gold at the end of a
glorious rainbow it's not even about
becoming something extraordinary and
waiting for the results of that
it's simply understanding that the one
thing you can control are your actions
today the choices that you make what you
get to do how you think about yourself
the beliefs you choose to bring into
your life those things you control
and when you understand the power in
acknowledging that control and taking
control and using it
that's when your life is going to begin
to change but first you have to divorce
yourself from being obsessively
interested only in an outcome
if instead you build your self-esteem
you build your pride on pursuit
you build your pride on allowing
yourself to care about something so
deeply that even though tomorrow is not
guaranteed that you're going to plant
your apple tree today that you're going
to love that process because it is the
thing you can control you can control
how you show up you can control how you
play you cannot control how other people
react
you cannot control what they think about
you
but you can control what you think about
yourself how do i stop myself from
beating myself up for trying to do
something that failed miserably and then
continuing to overthink everything about
what happened thank you so much for any
advice and assistance that you can
provide okay
here is how to conceptualize failure and
the disappointment that goes along with
it
once you understand that what the human
animal is designed to do is learn then
you have to ask yourself if what has
made the human animal the most apex of
apex predators the world has ever seen
the most capable of completely changing
its environment
what is it that allows them to learn
fast
and the answer is failure now the reason
that failure is truly useful and i'm not
just saying that to make you or myself
feel better in fact i wish that it
wasn't the way to learn the fastest but
the reality is the reason that it works
so well
is that when you fail you trigger areas
of the brain that are focused on
memory and focus
so you've got the memory side so you're
going to remember this you've got the
pain this does not feel good i do not
want to go through this again so you've
got that which heightens your emotions
which makes you more likely to remember
this thing moving forward and then it
also narrows your attention so you're
really looking at
why did this go wrong and when you have
this sense of i never want to repeat
this and you're looking very closely at
why did this go wrong now all of a
sudden
failures because of what it does to your
brain and quite frankly because you're
in the mix you're trying things and we
learn better from doing than from
reading about it or hearing about it
so failures suddenly become the most
information rich data stream on planet
earth heightens your likelihood of
remembering and it focuses you in on
exactly what's the problem so now
even though failing
part of what makes it valuable is that
it's
in fact it may
in order to make it valuable let that
sink in that nature went huh when this
happens in order for this to be useful
for this animal for this evolutionary
creature i need to make sure
that it becomes advantageous so that as
they make mistakes assuming that they
don't get eaten by a lion i want to make
sure that they don't put themselves in
that position again and so we have to
learn from
some method and the method that gets us
moving taking action trying things
feeling the pain focusing that's going
to be the thing that we're going to get
the most takeaways from so now
as you reframe what failure is
failure
is not
proof that you're a loser
failure is the process by which you
become better okay failure is not the
process that reveals that you're a loser
failure is a process by which you become
better that is the name of failure so
now when you fail why would you beat
yourself up over it it's the nature of
progress itself
there is no way to get better without
failing it's the fastest way it is the
most effective way it is necessary you
have to do it and by the way for you to
have failed at something you showed the
courage to try it
so instead of wasting time beating
yourself up over the fact that something
went wrong we're going to say
that's the nature of progress we have to
try something it's not going to work as
well as we want it to or i may fall flat
on my face i may outright embarrass
myself and if i let that break me i will
fail to learn the lesson
but if i do what nature is compelling me
to do
and i focus
on what went wrong why did this happen
because i never want to go through this
again
you stack enough of those what went
wrong i never want to go through this
again enough of those together
and you actually get good
and translating potential into skill set
is the name of the game and you will
never do that more efficiently than you
will through failure and mistakes so
allowing yourself to wallow in
disappointment
doesn't make any sense it's the learning
process this is what you have to do in
order to get good so there's no reason
to spend a lot of time being
disappointed you brush yourself off you
pick yourself up you dust yourself off
and you get going scott belski said when
99 of the people doubt your idea you're
either gravely wrong or about to make
history
and that's the terrifying part
you're not gonna know
you're not gonna know the difference but
if you're chasing somebody else's path
if your whole game is emulation if your
whole game is to mimic that which
inspires you you will never find the
thing that's real about you
and look i don't know about you but i
can be wrong i can be gravely wrong i
can have people think me an idiot and
try something and fail as long as it was
true to me because then the lesson that
i'm going to learn is going to apply
it's going to take me another step
closer to actually being the person that
i want to become that i want to live
with every day
i can't be that
if i don't understand
who i want to be
so look inward identify your path
identify what excites you and go after
it as if your life depends on it
because in truth it does you can choose
to believe in luck you can choose to
believe that you don't have control that
you don't have agency that the world is
happening to you
or
you can choose to recognize
that cause and effect exists that if you
want to get better at something you need
to put in the work that if you want to
get stronger you need to lift heavier
weights
that you can either ask for stronger
shoulders to carry a bigger load or you
can ask for a lighter load the choice is
yours but at the end of the day if you
want those strong shoulders they're
yours to
build you've got to make those choices
you've got to understand the cause and
effect you've got to understand that
your life right now
is the exact
reflection
of your
choices
your life the good the bad the ugly the
hateful the painful the joyful the
beautiful everything in your life
is a reflection
of you it's a reflection of the things
you've decided to do it's a reflection
of the things you've decided not to do
it's the story you tell yourself about
yourself what you believe is capable
all of those things
they're the choices that you're making
every day and at any time you can choose
to make a different choice
and as bruce lee said if you always put
limits on everything you do physical or
anything else it will spread into your
work and into your life there are no
limits
there are only plateaus and you must not
stay there
you must go beyond them
even in the statement you can see him
making the choice about what to believe
by saying that there are no limits by
taking something that other people
perceive as a limit it's something
that's stopping him and saying that's
not it's a plateau it's something that i
can push through and you see what he
holds himself accountable to
it's not okay to stay at a plateau it's
okay to have one everybody has them they
happen it's a natural part of the course
of getting better but it is not okay to
stay there and that is a choice that's
not something anyone can hand you it's
something you have to believe to the
core of your soul that it is not okay
to stay in a plateau and it's that
that's gonna push you through it's that
that's gonna make you get up and keep
going but first
you have to recognize that life is cause
and effect you have to recognize that
that choice is a knock on effect you
have to recognize that him merely saying
those words out loud
have a cause and effect
they changed the course of his life the
expectations that other people have him
expectations that he has of himself and
because he understands that he can
control
the outside world by first controlling
what's inside by changing his belief
system to match what he wants to
accomplish
he's then able to accomplish
what he did in his life had nothing to
do with luck
it had everything to do with the demands
that he made on himself it had to do
with when he got in a motorcycle
accident people told him he would never
walk again not only did he walk again
all of the major accomplishments that we
think about of being that man
they all came after
they came after he was told he was never
going to walk came after he was told
that he was never going to be able to do
martial arts but he did it he did the
grueling work of getting better he
understood cause and effect he
understood that if he chose to believe
that he could never do it
that he'd never be able to do it
but that if he chose to believe that by
working out he could get stronger and
get better and get back to it than he
could and that's what he did
[Music]
so now ask yourself
is your life dictated by luck
or cause and effect
are you in control or is it somebody
else
is someone else in control
or is it you
and if it's you
go build the life that you want because
there's nothing stopping you but you and
as joseph campbell said
people say what we're all seeking is a
meaning for life but i don't think
that's what we're really seeking i think
what we're seeking is the experience of
truly being alive
and that's it
that's the juice
figuring out that thing that makes you
come alive
it isn't
keeping up with the joneses it isn't how
much you're getting paid it isn't
anything other than for you
something very specific will be
different for everyone but for you
find that thing
that makes you come alive
focus on it think about it put your time
and attention there shift away from
seeing the pain in the opera and instead
seeing the wonderment in it all seeing
the glory that is just
everything around you the opportunities
the fact that you're alive once you can
see that those basic things that you
take for granted that you can breathe in
through the nose and out through the
mouth all of that stuff once you start
seeing how miraculous it really is once
you start seeing how we're connected to
each other once you understand that the
name of the game isn't wealth it isn't
fame it isn't
ambition or success
it's neurochemistry
it's feeling a certain way
it's finding fulfillment in your life
once you realize that
you'll understand this is a game of
attention
and you entirely control what you focus
on
so choose
very wisely my friends because your life
will literally become
the summation of the things
that you look at albert einstein said
everybody's a genius but if you judge a
fish by its ability to climb a tree it
will live its whole life believing that
it's stupid
and that's what confuses people
people believe that they're done because
they're not finding
their path they're not defining things
based on what excites them and what they
want to live with every day they're just
looking to what the outside world says
is good and i think it's incredible that
there are other people doing things that
are so extraordinary that we aspire to
be like that you have to understand the
difference between being like
someone
and trying to actually
be them
so if what inspires you is that somebody
works hard work hard if what inspires
you is that somebody gets up every time
they fail get up every time you fail
if what you like is that they are
themselves with all their weird
eccentricities and quirks then be true
to your eccentricities and quirks but
don't try to embody their eccentricities
and quarks that's the surest way to
become the fish that thinks it's stupid
because it's being judged by trying to
climb a tree one of the most surreal
things about my experience as an
entrepreneur is that the better i get at
it the more that i do the more i feel
lost the more i feel like there's too
much for me to possibly know and
understand and in that
is my power that's literally the source
of my power because i understand that my
journey is one of learning i understand
that as naval ravicant said the genuine
love for reading itself when cultivated
is a superpower
the means of learning are abundant it's
the desire to learn that's scarce
but if you have that desire if you
cultivate that desire to learn if you
accept that you're in this big world
that is far too big for you to
understand every piece of it but in
recognizing that you don't understand it
all and putting yourself on this quest
to learn obsessively to get better to
fall in love with the actual
process of gaining knowledge if you stay
hungry for that at all times and you
don't
calcify your thoughts into dogma but
rather stay fresh stay naive stay hungry
and foolish to really learn and grow
then you actually obtain power and this
is the part i want people to understand
look past the words and hear what i'm
really saying as you take on the
knowledge as you're learning one thing
after another after another those skills
have practical application and it is
that practical application born of
understanding how little you really know
that allows you to become far more
powerful than the people that think
they know because when they think they
know they stop growing and they think
they know they calcify when they think
they know their
thoughts get brittle like bone and break
but when you think you know nothing when
you think you have to learn everything
when you really just trying to figure
out if something works if it gets you
the result then those skills become real
they become tested by what you're doing
they are boundless because you're always
trying to find that next thing you're
never self satisfied you're never
self-congratulatory
you're simply asking where do i want to
go what skills do i need to acquire to
get there and knowing that each one of
those that you get brick by brick by
brick builds a real path to where you
want to go
so fall in love with the idea
that you know nothing fall in love with
the idea that learning is a superpower
fall in love with that hunger want that
want to get better every day never
never be tricked by the desire to be
self-satisfied never be tricked by the
desire to be great today never fool
yourself into thinking who you are today
is who you can become i don't care how
far you've come i don't care how many
accomplishments are in your rear-view
mirror if you fall prey to that your
past will always be bigger than your
future and there is one mandate that i
make of myself and anyone else that
wants to be around me your future must
always be bigger than your past
and the only way for that to be true
is to love
how little you really know
and to love how much you can learn
if you just keep
going
everything around you
is
incredible if you're willing to look at
it that way everything around you can be
taken for granted if that's your
perspective
but it really is about the frame that
you choose to put around things i mean
simply being alive is already insane the
odds are so stacked against you not only
just being a human but being a human at
this
moment in time this moment in time where
breakthroughs and technology are
happening at
at an unprecedented rate where
breakthroughs in medical science are
happening at an unprecedented rate where
our ability to connect with people to
empathize with people all the way around
the globe all of the changes that have
happened in technology and telecom and
connectivity health everything
we're living in
the most miraculous time
ever
but you have to look at it that way
and as joseph campbell said life is a
wonderful wonderful opera
except that it hurts
so the question is do you see it as the
beautiful opera or do you just pay
attention to the pain
and at the end of the day you're going
to get what you focus on they're both
true
this is both the most amazing time
that's ever happened ever in recorded
history
and yet real things that are terrifying
are also happening
but where you put your energy where you
put your attention
where you put your focus is going to
determine what you see and that is the
most fascinating and the most important
thing you have to understand about the
way that your mind works you get what
you focus on if you focus on the things
that are bad they will become real they
will become exaggerated they will begin
to monopolize your thoughts you'll see
them everywhere it's called the
reticular activating system your mind is
literally designed
to pay attention
to the things that you notice
once you notice a certain car you see it
everywhere once you notice a certain dog
you see it everywhere once you hear a
certain name for the first time suddenly
realize that that name has been all
around you this entire time but now that
you're focusing on it now that you're
looking for it it is everywhere
so whatever you look for
it's going to be everywhere
if you look for the negative it'll be
there but if you look for the positive
it will overwhelm you step number one to
accomplishing whatever it is that you
want to do is actually getting started
and i understand i know the thing that
holds you back i know the thing that is
absolutely
paralyzing for people
is you don't think that you have what it
takes to go out and be good and rather
than face that difficult brutal process
of growing and getting better and quite
frankly facing your inadequacies
it's easier just to sit back but as john
wooden said never let what you cannot do
interfere with what you can there is
something right now that you're capable
of there is an innate skill inside of
you that's your spark it's that starting
point it's that thing that while you may
not be the best in the world at it it's
a flame that you can fan it's something
that you can breathe life into and
really begin to get good but first you
have to understand the very nature of
progress and that's as stephen covey
said
you're not the product of your
circumstances but rather a product of
your decisions and it's those decisions
that are going to allow you to build
that skill set so don't worry about
where you started don't worry about what
you already have remember it's the
decisions that you make it's going down
that road it is
the decision
to get started it's the decision to face
possible failure it's the decision to
get up once you failed and it's the
decision
of what to learn when you fail
do you learn that you're not good enough
do you learn you never should have tried
or do you learn a lesson from the
failure and get up and brush yourself
off and remember that at the end of the
day
you're going to go as far as you're
willing to fight for and that's it if
you're willing to fight to go all the
way then you will go that far you will
set a new bar you will define for people
what
is possible
you become that beacon of hope you
become that thing that other people look
to as the standard
but at the end of the day it started
with you getting started it started with
you showing up it started with you
pushing and trying
so get out there
don't worry about
what you have and what you are
focus on who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there as vaclav haval said
work for something because it is good
not just because it stands a chance to
succeed
this is something that i think a lot of
people misunderstand they think that the
goal of their life is to identify
something that'll work to identify
something that has the odds stacked in
its favor rather than to think about
what matters
what's important
because if something is important if it
speaks to you if it's going to
give resonance to your life then it's
worth doing even if it's something that
is almost guaranteed to fail when
something matters enough regardless of
the odds it's worth engaging with
because even in the pursuit
you can find meaning and as humans one
of the things that we hunger for most is
purpose and meaning but you can't have
that purpose and meaning without the
thing that you're pursuing be something
that you believe to be worthwhile so
don't worry about whether or not it
succeeds ask only about whether or not
it's going to light you on fire ask only
if in those dark moments that it will
give you that sense of mattering to this
world that even in the failure do you
learn something about yourself do you
see
the truth
that you matter
and that even as a single person even as
one individual you can echo through this
world
but that will never happen by pursuing
something small
that will never happen by pursuing
something simply because it can win
it will only happen by pursuing
something that matters
and in that if you pursue something that
matters and you're able to get to the
point where you can see it across the
finish line or at least advance it and
make it a step closer to becoming real
in that we realize how societies really
are transformed in that and trying the
big the impossible dreaming that thing
that nobody else is even willing to talk
about in dreaming that it is the crazy
ones who are able to change the world
because the crazy ones allowed
themselves to believe
they allowed themselves to believe that
against all the odds a world that does
not yet exist could actually exist
and as ralph marsden said welcome those
big sticky complicated problems in them
are your most powerful opportunities and
that's it the big problems the ones that
matter the things that will give you
purpose and meaning in your life they're
going to be hard but if you can look at
the hard things and show up and push
every day and keep striving and when you
fall down pick yourself back up and
focus only on one thing not whether or
not you're going to win but whether or
not it mattered that you played
if you do that
every sacrifice in your life will be
worth it
and if not
[Music]
nothing you gain
will have mattered this is why jocko
willing says discipline is freedom when
you know
i don't go outside of these lines i
don't break these rules these rules are
hard and fast they are bright lines now
there's no you know maybe i should maybe
i shouldn't it's like me and getting out
of bed in 10 minutes or less i never
want to every single day literally every
day of my life
my brain is kicking up excuses why today
i shouldn't have to get out of bed and
10 minutes less even i am startled that
after i've been doing this now for more
than 20 years even
20 years in
i still
have to fight every day but i have
bright lines so there's no excuse so
literally when i think oh well today you
don't have to for xyz reasons
my conscious mind i've repeated it so
many times is this is a bright line
there are no excuses there is no reason
there is no if ands or buts you get out
of bed in 10 minutes or less full stop
period end of story
and so therefore i get out of bed but
you have to know what you're striving
for you have to know why you're doing
all of this why you're putting in all
these rules and it has to be something
you're actually interested in you're
actually excited about otherwise why why
are you limiting your life like this why
are you narrowing things down okay why
not go get the dopamine hit from the
fridge you have to have a reason
right you've got to know why you eat a
certain way or don't eat a certain way
you've got to know why you're working
this hard you've got to know why you
push through the difficult things okay
nietzsche's quote the person
with the right why can survive almost
anyhow okay you have to know what your
why is you've got to know why you're
pushing through all this stuff but once
you have that
you'll be able to slap some rules on
this and get to the other side what
steps did you take to separate business
growth from personal growth i often find
myself confused on which one to grow but
i do know that if you don't grow your
business won't grow either any tips so
for me they're inextricably connected
and my advice to anybody whether you're
a linchpin employee or whether you're an
entrepreneur there should not be any
difference between yourself as a person
and what you're doing as a job you spend
50 percent of your waking hours at your
job 50
of your waking hours are at your job
so and that's assuming i think i did the
math at like a 40 or 50 hour work week
so if you work
as much as i do where it's like
90 hours sometimes more then it's like
okay at some point like if there is a
difference between who you are as a
person the things you want to learn and
grow and get better at and what you're
spending all that time on
i don't think you're going to look back
to favorably on your life and quite
frankly i don't think you're going to
enjoy the moment because i'm not a
legacy guy i don't think about like i
literally i am not at all worried about
what i'm going to think on my deathbed
because hopefully my deathbed isn't a
very long endeavor so i would rather
live my life the way that i'm enjoying
it right now today like i'll just tell
you i'm going to regret on my deathbed i
will for sure regret not having kids a
hundred percent like that is so patently
obvious to me and when people ask like
aren't you worried you're going to
regret it not even a little bit because
i would regret having kids today and
today hopefully is a lot longer because
you got a whole lot of today's than your
deathbed so to me optimize for what
makes you feel the most alive every day
in the struggle because the struggle is
guaranteed so that's where i like to
spend my time thinking about that
thinking about the things that are
making me the person that i want to
become right now in the moment if i'm
fighting with something at work that i'm
still having to learn the skills that i
would want to learn even if i wasn't at
work and so yeah that's it i think that
you can find that whether you're a
linchpin employee or whether you're an
entrepreneur you just have to select the
company that you work for or the company
that you create very very very carefully
as michelangelo said
if people knew how hard i worked to
achieve my mastery
it wouldn't seem so wonderful after all
and that's the thing about getting great
that's the thing about being an artist
of such caliber that you're remembered
for hundreds of years after your death
it is back-breaking work it is a
blinding amount of effort it isn't about
natural talent that myth that some
people are born with something that we
celebrate so much
is just that
a myth
you're born a lump of flesh you can't
hold your own head up you may have
predispositions but that is a long way
from actually crafting your ability
until the point where it looks like
magic
and that's the beauty of artistry isn't
it
that it's so unbelievable that you're
more willing to believe that it was
god-given that they were anointed with
it
then that they just worked their ass off
but the truth is
every one of the greats no matter how
much natural talent they were born with
they're remembered because they worked
they are remembered because they did so
much work
because in that work
is hardship in that work is difficulty
in that work is unbearable
adversity
but it's in that adversity that the
magic happens and as victor hugo said
adversity makes men
prosperity makes monsters so i know
right now you wish you'd been born with
some talent you wish that all those
dreams that you had they were yours for
the taking that you didn't have to put
blood sweat and tears into it that
somebody would hand you at least
something in the beginning that they
would give you some start some
that's where the monster's created if
you really want to get hard if you
really want to get tough if you want to
get great if you want to be untouchable
because no one can bend or break your
vision of yourself
then you have to
suffer that's the way of the world
and as florence nightingale said i
attribute my success to this
i never gave or took
any excuse
[Music]
and that's the secret
at the end of the day if you know what
you want it's only a question of whether
you're willing to pay the price to get
there
so ask yourself
are you willing to pay the price if you
almost play a game with yourself and say
i want to see if i can change the energy
of somebody who's being difficult i want
to see if i can stay
compassionate generous kind warm through
all of this don't get me [ __ ] wrong
sometimes it's really hard especially if
it's your kids or your parents or your
spouse like it can be hard i get it
but as we
try to
be our best selves and present ourselves
in a way that's going to get us what we
want which is a harmonious relationship
which is the ending of the difficulty by
looking at what we could do to change
that situation you will be shocked at
how far that goes
figuring out how to point out the
scaffolding of a conversation is huge
breaking things down into small pieces
being generous and articulating their
stance
recognizing a collision of values and
knowing hey
if we can't agree on where we're trying
to end up if we can't agree on what the
value is
this is going to be a fruitless
conversation and the sooner you
recognize that's where you're at and
that you need to actually talk about the
value or just go your separate ways
the healthier all of your relationships
are going to be and then just lead with
kindness and recognize that people that
think differently that's important and
we shouldn't
want everybody to see the world exactly
the way that we see it
and
if we can come at things from that
perspective of trying to understand
before we try to be understood
you're going to find that a lot of that
difficulty just goes by the wayside
and that's how i deal with difficult
people as thomas edison said
our greatest weakness lies in giving up
the most certain way to succeed is to
always try
one
more time
i know there are going to be a million
times in your life where you want to
give up where you absolutely ache with
the desire to quit where nothing sits
inside of your gut other than the
certainty that you are going to fail
that you are not good enough to push
forward but that is to fundamentally
misunderstand the nature of a failure
the nature of a failure is not to tell
you who you are
the nature of a failure is to tell you a
way that didn't work it's to inform it's
to educate you
it's to test you it's to be a gut check
to find out if you believe in yourself
enough to push forward even when the
world seems to be telling you not to
and as brian tracy said
attempt the impossible
in order to improve your work
think about that for a second attempt
the impossible just to get better to try
the things that you know are going to
fail things that the world is going to
tell you simply cannot be but even if it
violates the laws of physics if there's
something in that attempt that you're
going to learn you owe it to yourself
you have a moral obligation
to try
because all of the people that will lie
in your wake are the people that didn't
try simply because they didn't believe
that they could do it
you have to be willing to look at the
world you have to be willing to see
things that you yourself think are
impossible and try because in that you
will stretch yourself you have to be
willing to look inward at the state of
your current skill set and say i'm going
to play outside of that i'm not going to
play word safe i'm going to play where
it hurts i'm going to play where i feel
clumsy i'm going to play only in the
areas that make me feel stupid because
in that i know that the way that the
brain responds is through adaptation but
i have to stress
myself you can't ever lose sight of that
the only way that the human animal
adapts is through stress
you have to be willing to break things
in order to build something new so if
you want to push the boundaries if you
want to see just how far you can go if
you want to succeed at the highest level
if you want to play on a global scale
you have got to be willing to try the
impossible because right now
the things that you need to do are
impossible for you
but they won't remain that way forever
and as aristotle said
pleasure in the job
puts perfection in the work
this doesn't have to be a tale of always
being terrified everybody myself
included screaming at you telling you
that you need to go do something great
the part they're leaving out is why the
should you care
you should care because it's the
greatest joy
you should only listen to this
if it's leading you down a path that
makes you feel more alive and that's the
point the point is to get in touch with
something that makes you feel great but
not to let yourself starve or be stopped
by a fear that you'll fail
by a fear that it can't be done
have fun have the guts to enjoy yourself
have the guts to go out and attempt
something audacious and terrifying
knowing that all along if you're doing
it right you're gonna have a good time
so all of this going balls out trying to
prove something to yourself trying to do
something amazing
never lose sight
that it's to build a better life never
lose sight of the fact that you're doing
it
to create
the person that you want to be never
lose sight of the fact
that it should be fun the most powerful
weapon that you're going to have at your
disposal isn't a gun it isn't a sword it
isn't a bomb the most powerful weapon
you will ever have at your disposal if
you really want to make change
is knowledge
it doesn't mean going to school it can
be school it can be books it can be a
mentor it can be somebody else's failure
it can be your own
failure
but whatever it is to always be learning
to be learning something today knowing
that that's an investment and as robert
louis stevenson said don't judge each
day by the harvest you reap
but rather by the seeds you plant
and that's what knowledge is that's what
the learning process is is you're
learning something today that you may
not even understand how it's going to be
valuable
but one day
that piece of knowledge is going to come
to your aid one day that thing that you
learned is going to be something that
you're going to lean on one day that
thing that you've worked your ass off to
understand better than anybody else in
the world
it's going to help you change
the world
but you have to be doing it now you have
to be learning with an obsession you
have to understand that ideas in equal
ideas out and that you have to chase
that knowledge down that it is a
relentless pursuit and that like you
would build an armada like you would
create a stock pile of weapons you must
create a stockpile of knowledge you must
learn and learn and learn and you must
hold yourself accountable every day to
planting those seeds to getting better
to learning more to understanding things
more broadly when you do that there will
be nothing that won't be unlocked to you
that's what i want you guys to
understand it doesn't matter where you
are now it doesn't matter where you
started your circumstances the money the
people that you know none of it matters
what matters is how much you willing to
learn how good are you willing to get
how much knowledge are you willing to
soak in because that
will become your weapon that will be how
you rise up and that will be the thing
that will protect you when you need it
most zen she says flower does not think
about competing with a flower next to it
it just blooms and that's really your
job is to see the outside world to see
the flower next to you to understand the
amazing things that are happening all
around you all of the incredible people
and the essence of what they have and
what it is that they've done to bring
inside yourself and find out what does
that look like
when it's me
not what do i look like when i'm them
and once you understand the difference
between that then you can really begin
to be something unique you can become
that thing that you were meant to be
that thing that makes you feel alive and
whole and that's it that's the secret
you're just trying to be something not
that's just inspiring to other people
but that you actually want to wake up
every day and be and that's the thing
about it
so escaping you
whatever you become a lie the truth
somebody else yourself whatever it is
you spend every day of your life there
as helen keller said
optimism is the faith that leads to
achievement
nothing can be done without hope and
confidence
and that's the trick it really is faith
it really is doing something even though
you have nothing in the world telling
you that it's real it's something that
you have to choose to believe in it's
something that is going to allow you to
do incredible things simply because you
believe that you can do them but if you
don't start with that optimistic belief
if you don't start by burning into
yourself by reinforcing over and over
and over in your mind
that things can and will work out that
your efforts are going to be rewarded to
believe to the core of your being that
the harder you work the more you're
going to learn the more you learn the
more you'll be able to do the more
you'll be able to do the more you'll be
able to manifest your dreams
but you have to start with that faith
that that's real
because it would be just as easy to look
at the world and say the pessimism is
the only thing that makes sense it would
be just as easy to look into the world
and see only the negative things
but once you understand that you can
choose to have faith that things are
going to work that you can believe in
something long before you have the
evidence for it and you can believe in
it because you know that's how the mind
works
that we lead with belief that's where
humans generate their power they don't
generate it from seeing some evidence of
something in the world we generate our
power by first believing that our
efforts will be rewarded you have to put
that at the center of your being
and as wayne dyer said be miserable or
motivate yourself whatever has to be
done is always your
choice
so if you want to do something
recognize there's no obstacle holding
you back other than what you choose to
believe
and if you want to be miserable it's
going to be there for you and if you
want to be empowered it's there for you
if you want strength it is there for you
it's a decision it's something that you
decide to believe in that you can get
strong
and that ultimately is the ultimate
strength to believe that you can
get better to believe that you can
become whatever you want to become so
choose optimism right now choose to let
it feel you choose to feel it to sit in
that sensation that anything you set
your mind to is possible when you allow
yourself to embody that to believe it no
matter what anybody tells you no matter
how many people tell you that you're
stupid you're a failure that you're
never going to do anything that you are
going to believe in yourself
if you can do that if you can choose
that optimism
you can go anywhere
because you realize everything you
needed was in you all along
it was simply choosing to believe you
could execute against it
so have
that faith
go out and do it the world that we're
all living in is our own construction
and i think that's the thing that people
are missing we have literally created
this world and if this world is delusion
if this world is destruction if this
world is filled with more bad than it is
good
then that is a process of our thinking
that is a revelation
of how our minds work it is a revelation
of what we have built internally
so as leo tolstoy said everyone thinks
of changing the world but no one thinks
of changing themselves if we're actually
going to make change in the world if
those things that you have in your mind
the vision of what you want to bring to
the world all of the ills that you want
to correct if you're actually going to
correct them
you have to look inward and begin asking
how is this your responsibility what are
the things in your thinking
that have helped manifest this world
that have manifested the problems in
your own life and that will my friends i
promise you
manifest the solutions
and as stephen hawking pointed out
the greatest enemy of knowledge is not
ignorance
it's the illusion of knowledge we think
we know something that we don't we think
we have the answers we think within us
already right now or the fundamental
building blocks that we're going to need
in order to build something new but the
truth is
the only thing that we already have is
the willingness to look
the willingness to change to leverage
the things that we have but we have to
build something entirely new we have to
understand that we don't yet know enough
that we are not adequate that we have to
look at ourselves and be willing to
stare nakedly at our inadequacies and to
adjust them to fix them to not hide
behind ego to not pretend or worse
believe
[Music]
that we're already who we need to be
because the only promise i can make you
is you're not yet the person you need to
be to execute to create the change that
you want to make
but i can also promise you
that you can become that
that if you're willing to do the hard
work of looking internally and building
something new if you're willing to tear
yourself down if you're willing to brick
by brick disassemble that thing that has
been built by accident inside of you and
move forward with a new level of
intention and build something an
entirely new structure with your eyes
open with embracing and accepting
a lack of knowledge but never ignorance
of not
holding on to old ideas but to ask of
everything that you choose to believe
does this move me towards my goals or
not and if it does then you do it if it
does you believe it even more but if it
doesn't right then right there you drop
it
then you make room for the new
then you can build
what you want to build
then
we'll have the change that we want as
gloria steinem says
the truth will set you free
but first it will piss you off the
reality is if you want to achieve
something great in your life you've got
to be willing to accept who you really
are right now you've got to know exactly
what you're good at and what you're not
and the reason that the truth is going
to piss you off is it's going to hurt
it's going to hurt to acknowledge that
you're not yet who you want to be it's
going to hurt to know that you're not
yet capable of the things that you want
to be capable of and it's really going
to hurt
to know that the things that people say
behind your back the things that they
say to hurt you
that they're actually true
that they're right
they have a point you aren't good at
that thing you aren't as good as you
could be you did embarrass yourself you
have fallen down all of those things are
almost certainly true
but when you can look at those things
when you can stare nakedly at your
inadequacies when you can really stop
and not protect yourself with ego but
protect yourself by knowing that you're
gonna learn from where you failed you're
going to learn from the places you've
fallen down you're going to learn your
inadequacies so that you can build
something new so that you can move from
that place into a place of purpose into
a place of skill set where you can
dominate the field because you've built
those skills but if you don't first
acknowledge that you need to build them
you can never begin the process in
earnest
and as michio kaku says
all great ideas come from a picture
you've got to know what you want you've
got to know what that thing is that
you're building towards you've got to
know exactly who you're trying to become
and once you have that crystal clear
vision of who you want to be
it is far easier to acknowledge who you
really are
so you've got to start with that picture
you've got to accept the reality pain
and all
you've got to have that picture you've
got to know where you're going you've
got to know what the skills are that you
need to build in order to get there and
once you do that once you have that
picture and that picture is your
obsession it's the thing that you think
about you dream about you put it up on
your wall you tattoo it in your mind you
know exactly who you're trying to become
if you do that
if you're honest with yourself about
where you are
and you know exactly where you want to
go
how do i focus on accomplishing one
thing at a time when i have so much to
do in one day what's the best way to
give your attention to what matters
while still accomplishing the other
things that need to get done
example i have lots of schoolwork to do
every day but also want to spend time
learning the things i need to achieve my
goals all right so this is all about
getting really efficient with your time
so you're going to want to make a list i
titled mine important things entitle
yours whatever you think is best and on
that list it's it's all action items so
it isn't just pontification it's going
to be here are the things that i need to
do and in order so make sure that
they're in order of what tim ferriss
calls the lead domino so you want to
knock over that um the thing that then
will cause other things to fall over
first
excuse me so
find that lead domino make sure that
you're doing that first do the hard
things do the important things do them
in order and make sure that you're
blocking out your time make sure you
also carve out time to think so you need
both but um at the end of the day if
you're not taking action nothing matters
so i would keep that list and i would
live in that list and i would just
constantly be going through that list to
make sure that i'm moving the most
important things forward first
and then make sure that you're being
deadly efficient with your time so if
you audit your time i think you'd be as
horrified as if you audit what you
actually eat and most people don't
realize how many weird little calories
they slip in here and there especially
if you have kids and you're eating a
french fry or two after plate you're
having some of their macaroni it's like
time is exactly the same like how much
time did you spend at the water cooler
just chatting how much time did you
spend on reddit like all these things
end up sucking away a lot of your time
and people don't realize how much of
their time they lose to that so getting
deadly efficient with your time i think
you'll find that you have plenty of time
to do things sequentially you can't do
everything you want at the same time but
you can certainly do them sequentially
if you're really efficient with your
time i like jordan peterson's idea of
tell the truth or at least try not to
lie
sometimes
there can be a truth that
we leave unsaid
because this is a momentary interaction
where i would say kindness is the higher
value than pointing out every flaw that
we see or every bit of obnoxious
behavior
because at some point it just spirals
into madness to point out every misstep
that somebody is doing
and so when i look at somebody that is
being obnoxious being rude
my goal is to shift their energy
how can i get them back into a place
where they're feeling good they're
feeling warmth they are
in a place where they
feel kind right because most people it
isn't that they are incapable of
kindness and if they are like imagine
how
that life would be somebody who never
experiences kindness joy warmth
connection
that would truly be its own hell
so i'm not going to
worry about pointing out every obnoxious
thing that they're doing and i would
play a game with myself of how much joy
can i spread
and
in some ways
you are
leaving a truth unsaid which is that
they're being unkind or obnoxious or
whatever
but by trying to spread kindness you're
not lying and
especially if
you share
that value with me of wanting to just
put as much good vibes into the world as
you can and look i'm not perfect and
there is no doubt that sometimes people
are just like god damn like i just don't
want anything to do with it
but that doesn't feel like me at my best
me at my best feels like all right cool
can we switch this energy around can we
get them to soften to
feel
that human warmth and a bit of
connection and can i
i mean with a smile you will be shocked
how much you can change somebody's
demeanor so that's how i would flip it i
would just see how much joy can i spread
even when people are being problematic
to me now that doesn't mean that i'd let
people abuse me or anything like that i
don't i imagine you guys can get a
pretty good guess about
what i'm like i don't let people walk
over me or be a dick to me or whatever
but i find it far more interesting to
try to change somebody's energy then to
get them to go yeah i am being a dick
that's just not interesting to me trying
to get them to sort of confess
that they're the problem
i'd much rather hold myself accountable
to like how much
sort of emotional jiu-jitsu can i do
here a lot of people struggle with their
family now here is
the hard reality to be faced
for a lot of toxic people the right
answer is to just
distance yourself to not be around them
to
close that door create the boundaries
and make sure that you don't have to
deal with them and the reality is that
option is on the table even for family
but if you guys are anything like me the
idea of
cutting them out of your life even if
they're difficult
i'm grateful that i don't have toxic
people in my immediate family that is
for sure but
nonetheless
there are certain people that i wouldn't
cut out of my life no matter what their
mindset is and so because that's the
harder group to deal with i want to
address that first so let's say that
there's somebody in your life it could
be your parents could be a sibling could
be a loved one
and for whatever reason you're unwilling
to carve out that boundary and just say
i'm not going to have them in my life
then it becomes
part of the toxicity is that you're
taking on what they're saying and this
is where i want you guys to understand
you don't even have to make a big scene
about
it when people try to put something on
me tell me that i can't be something i
can't do something the way that i live
my life is a mistake and i'm hurting
myself and i'm hurting other people
i don't have to take that on just
because they believe it and then more
importantly i don't have to convince
them otherwise so it is okay for people
to have a negative opinion about you and
one thing that i want you guys to
understand is when somebody is coming at
something with that kind of negativity
when where they live
is a negative place when their world
view is this dark and gloomy place such
that they feel the need to moralize to
other people to tell them what they're
doing is wrong that is such
a gnarly place to live
it is a
corrosive
mentality
and so people that imbue that
not only do you not need to take it on
not only do you not need to convince
them but the thing that's probably going
to serve you the best in that moment is
compassion to understand
that living in that mentality
of
self-righteousness of
seeing the faults in other people
without having the self-awareness to
see your own mistakes your own foibles
the the problems with your own mentality
to be so outwardly focused that you feel
that you need to go around telling other
people how to live or to judge them
that is a punishment unto itself and
part of the reason that it's a
punishment unto itself is any time that
you are looking to the outside world for
the problems you fail
to recognize in yourself your own
deficiencies which stop you from
progressing now if i'm right that
progress is a foundational pillar to
human happiness which everything i know
about life and humans
reinforces that that is a true statement
then anything that stops you
from seeing yourself clearly
is something that holds you back it
stops you from having that progress it
stops you from building a life of joy
and at the end of the day living a
joyful life is really the sum total of
this so when people are coming after you
like that and they're not coming to you
from a place of compassion or empathy
that darkness that bitterness that anger
that vitriol is its own punishment it is
corrosive it does hold people back it
will stop them from ever having the
joyful life that they want the most
joyful people in the world the only
fingers they ever point are thumbs
and they point them back at themselves
and
when you look for what you can control
when you look for the things that you
can do differently in your life to get a
different result
now all of a sudden you realize that
you're not out of control you're not
powerless there's no reason to feel
hopeless because
you can get better you can improve you
can recognize where you are deficient
you can recognize what your goals demand
of you and then you can just go about
building that skill set improving
yourself and getting the outcomes that
you want in life and that progress
that progress in and of itself is the
reward it is the thing that leads to joy
ray dalio has a principle called
believability everybody needs a
believability score now this guy takes
it to the extreme and by the way i just
took a note for us to really implement
this stuff here we're gonna have to
figure out how everyone needs an actual
numerical value that each of us can look
at and say this is chase's believability
score this is tom's believability score
so you really do have to like make it
quantifiable so
if somebody's giving you advice about
something that they have not done in
their own life then they have basically
a zero believability score and somebody
who has a zero believability score
shouldn't be pushing their idea like
they know something they should be
asking a lot of questions now when
you're talking to somebody that's done
and ray dalio saying is three times or
more if they've successfully done
something three times or more then they
have believability in that area so you
want to find people that have
believability that really know what
they're talking about
and
then you should listen you should ask a
lot of questions you should really come
to understand it if they haven't done
that they may still have amazing ideas
but what you need because the
um you know sometimes a novice has
really fresh insights because they're
just not stuck in the dogmatic ways of
thinking that experts usually get into
but you need to be thinking about it
differently so rather than listening to
their conclusions you should be trying
to understand their methodology how did
they get there what is their process
their reasoning for making the statement
that they're making now if their
reasoning is sound then their conclusion
may very well be worthwhile but you have
to understand their reasoning so one of
those two things so either they are an
expert in that area and thusly you
should listen or they are not and you
should only be thinking about what their
process was to get to that conclusion
then you have to be able to derive your
own assessment as to whether or not you
should listen to them there's not going
to be anything more empirical than that
one of the goals of my life
is to get to the point where
in 30 seconds or less
i can change the course of somebody's
life through
magic words for lack of a better way to
think of it
and i'm really trying
and it won't give up
but as of right now
the only solution that i have when you
love somebody
that is stuck in negativity
is what i call just sit
if i know i'm gonna spend time with them
and i can't break them out of their
negative ways then i'm just gonna sit
and be with them and i'm gonna love them
and i'm gonna make sure that they know
that i love them and
i'll live my life without judgment
without needing them to change without
um trying to preach to them i'm just
gonna be with them and find things that
we can talk about that's fun there's
almost always something that even the
most negative person loves and if you
can find that thing fishing
card collecting
hawaii whatever
somebody's thing is whatever it is that
they like to talk about and you get them
onto that subject you'll actually have
fun it's really surprising my my dad's
wife is way into quilting now
i can't tell you how not into quilting i
am
but she's really passionate about it
and having a conversation with her about
quilting is so interesting because she's
so passionate
and whenever you can get somebody on to
something that they're passionate about
whether they're a positive person or a
negative person it gets to be a pretty
fun place so i just sit i try to find
things that they're going to be excited
to talk about and my whole goal is to
make them feel loved where they're at
now i live my life the way i'm going to
live it i don't join them in negativity
i don't you know go in on those
conversations but i don't want them to
feel judged i don't want to put distance
between us
um you know there's nothing worse than
making somebody that you love and care
about feel judged which of course i was
by even though i was just trying to help
i didn't want to see them suffer anymore
in constantly trying like saying hey
you're doing this wrong like there's a
better way you'll be happier
it just made them feel judged and it was
putting tremendous distance between me
and somebody that i cared about so
it works it will work every time but you
have to let go and know that they're
going to suffer until they're ready to
change i think it is very instructive
for people to ask the question who's
living my ideal life
and that doesn't mean who's making the
most money it means what person's life
do you want to live the real day-to-day
grind of it and when you identify what
your dream job is now we need to go
about figuring out how we get that job
and so very quickly a question about
managing our adhd and figuring out how
to stay focused actually becomes a
question of how do we get good at
finding the right job and so if you
think about
orchestrating your life
and most people live
by the law of accident
i want to repeat that most people live
by the law of accident don't let that be
you right you bump into somebody they
know there's a job offering or it's
closer to where you live or it's you
know easier for you with the kids
whatever and so you bump into these
things it's like oh yeah cool i'll make
that little thing and instead of
designing your life you end up just
responding to sort of little bumps along
the road that end up leading you down a
path that was never a conscious choice
you want to sit down and map out okay we
know that we have we need a job that
meets certain criteria and one piece of
that criteria is that it allows you to
be very physical and get that energy out
okay so
take control of your lives i cannot
stress that one enough journaling is
hugely important recognizing where you
thrive where you don't thrive what are
deal breakers so it sounds like eight
hours behind a desk is a deal breaker
for you so map out those things take
very strict control of your life and
remember
this may be one of the things that
that has led me to have a career
a life
that
has certainly led to a tremendous amount
of joy in my life and looks like from
the outside
impossible to obtain
i am an unreasonable person
and
i set aside all of my
lacking
elements all of my that's a weird way to
say inadequacies i set aside all the
things that i'm not good at because i
know it's all a process i can get good
at anything that i point myself at right
the only belief that matters if i put
time and attention to getting good at
this thing i actually will get good at
this thing
so i just set all of that aside okay
cool yeah whatever i'm not yet good
enough to have the life that i want my
ideal life but i'm gonna get good enough
and from that i
plant
a very unreasonable belief inside my
soul which is i can have any life i want
and now i just need to write out exactly
what that is i've hand crafted the life
that i desire and i know the realities
of who i am and what needs to be true in
order for me to
move well through the world right as
somebody who was diagnosed with adhd as
a kid i fully get it and so i have
tailored my life to that
momentum is everything to me because
i've got to always be moving i've got to
always feel like i can
have tomorrow be wildly different than
today
but i take responsibility for the fact
that i have to build that
and it's not going to happen by accident
the life i would be leading if i led my
life by accident would be radically
different it would not be tailored to
the things that i want
so don't be afraid to want
don't be afraid to spend an inordinate
amount of time thinking about what you
really want
and then don't be afraid to be
unreasonable in accepting nothing less i
get that humans do dumb things i get
that humans can be hurtful
i'm not interested though in what my
partner did wrong i'm only interested in
what i can do next time to avoid the
same mistakes without
diminishing the beauty that is a
relationship
now i have a fundamental belief that the
single greatest joy that anybody can
have in their life is to share a life
with somebody that they love and who
loves them that they trust and who trust
them
so i'm not gonna give up on that belief
because it went wrong one time two times
three times whatever i'm looking at what
i can control to make sure that i don't
end up back in that situation there's a
phrase that i think about often and that
is action cures all
if you have a problem i promise you
thinking about it isn't the solution
taking action is
hey like you i would go watch a
bazillion youtube videos but i wouldn't
watch a bazillion youtube videos on how
to do something before i tried it i
might watch a couple videos but i mean
literally a couple videos and then i
would immediately get involved in that
thing and you will find that in doing it
and trying to pull it off you learn
infinitely more you now have context for
what you're learning you now will maybe
steer your education in a different
direction i just cannot stress enough
you've got to take action you've got to
take action and in that all that din
that noise you're going to begin to
realize like wait a second these people
don't even know what they're talking
about because i'm actually out there
doing it these people do know what
they're talking about so i'm going to be
listening more to them but action cures
all like that has to be the mantra that
everybody lives by i cannot tell you
that the thing that has propelled me
forward is i'm so unafraid of
embarrassing myself
i know that when i get started on
something i'm gonna look stupid and my
willingness to look stupid and not try
to pose or look cool to go out there get
kicked in the face embarrass myself
recollect myself
and move forward that's how i keep
winning and irony of ironies is if you
recognize that you should never judge
yourself through the lens of a moment
you should only judge yourself through
the lens of a lifetime
or more practically three-year movements
ten-year movements when you start
thinking like that
then it's like i laugh because all the
people making fun of me on a long enough
timeline i will beat them all and i
really believe that going back to me
being a very unreasonable person i know
that i will win
on a long enough timeline i can be
anyone at anything because i have the
only belief that matters that if i put
time and energy into getting better at
something i will actually get better now
most people can't do it most people
cannot get their ego out of the way most
people can't eliminate the distractions
most people succumb to the paralysis of
indecision they're so afraid to be
embarrassed that they let that noise
right the the very well-defined sense of
distraction from other people's voices
stop them from growing from learning
from trying from taking
action
now if you take action and recognize
i'll get better these guys can make fun
of me they're never going to stick with
it they won't be able to deal with the
emotion of getting embarrassed of
failing at something of recognizing that
you truly aren't
good enough
yet now most people don't have the word
yet that you do
you will use that as a
weapon and i know people hate it when i
use war language
but i love it
you will use it as a weapon that you
will wield
in your quest for success all the
information that you need is out there
right now
go read a book go listen to a podcast
find somebody that's been successful in
the way that you want and listen to them
the bad news is you won't take all of
their advice you'll take some of it some
small percentage but the reality is
you're gonna have to go out and try and
suffer and fail all on your own to to
learn now the great news is it works and
it works really well and if you fail and
suffer and fall in your face and get
back up enough times and really reflect
on it then you're gonna get better and
ray dalio has an amazing math equation
which i'm going to use so much i think
it's really really powerful and that is
pain plus reflection equals progress and
i think that that's incredibly
incredibly true and the human animal
just needs that bit of pain it is the
compass that's going to allow you if you
reflect on why you're feeling that pain
what you did wrong how you failed you
don't deflect you don't make it somebody
else's problem you really just look at
how did i fit this up if you look at
that and are willing to make the changes
you really will make progress i don't
see a way to
really have grand scale change without
the suffering that's the truth all of
the you know self-improvement talk in
the world is useless if you don't learn
to become self-aware now here's the
great news this is a process
now there are certainly some people that
take to it a little bit more easily and
maybe you really struggle with
self-awareness but i'm going to walk you
quickly through the process of how to
gain some more self-awareness so it goes
like this in your body there's this
thing called the vagus nerve the vagus
nerve is the biggest nerve in your body
the vagus nerve
runs all over everywhere touches every
system goes into your gut down your
limbs everything
now
most people think of the body
as the brain telling your body what to
do and then a little bit of information
from the body if you hurt yourself or
whatever you're going to get a pain
signal or a pleasure signal but for the
most part it's a top-down system
read
lisa feldman barrett's book how emotions
are made
that book flips
all of this on its head
and what it explains is
that
it's basically an extrapolation of the
fact that the vagus nerve 80
of the data that it sends is from the
body to the brain
only 20 from the brain to the body think
about that and that emotions start in
the body so a big part of self-awareness
is getting in your body feeling your
body figuring out
how
a an emotion manifests itself does it do
you start to get flush do you feel
jittery are you anxious are you angry
beginning to identify the sensations in
your body because the way emotions are
made
you get a feeling in your body your body
then maps that feeling on to what was
happening the last time that you felt
that oh the last time you felt like that
you were angry the last time you felt
like that you were scared the last time
you felt like that you were in love
whatever and your body tries to map or
your brain tries to map that body
sensation onto a familiar state and then
once it goes ah yeah i know that this is
fear boom all the responses that come
with fear and you go and so one of the
ways that people talk about anxiety
at a physiological level
anxiety looks very similar to excitement
and so one of the loops that a cognitive
behavioral therapist for instance would
tell you to do is to go oh i know this
feeling this is excitement not oh i know
this feeling i'm super anxious oh i know
this feeling this is excitement and you
constantly work to reframe that feeling
as excitement now the super weird thing
is it works
your brain actually believes
what you tell it so your brain is quite
literally coming up with a
backwards compatible story to try to
make sense of the feeling
but it also allows you to put a
conscious
reinterpretation
on top
of that feeling
so now you're able to go
oh this isn't anxiety this is excitement
i feel
that what's coming is going to be fun
it's going to be exciting and that's why
my heart is beating faster that's why my
breath is getting more shallow because
i'm super excited to go do this thing
now when you first start doing it of
course it sounds like bs
and you're calling yourself out on it
but if you repeat it and you go through
that process enough it really does begin
to come true
the next part of the equation is just
getting really good at identifying the
signal
that your body's sending you so instead
of mapping it to sort of you know four
or five really basic primary emotions
fear excitement
joy
sadness whatever like those really sort
of primary colors of emotion
we get into a layer deeper and we start
beginning to identify
oh i get this is i'm feeling flustered
why am i feeling flustered oh they they
um
they're saying that i'm short and i'm
insecure about my height so oh man this
isn't me that i dislike them this is
that they're tapping into my insecurity
the biggest argument my wife and i
ever got into
was over a cup of tea
over a cup of tea we got into this huge
screaming match
it almost ended our vacation what little
vacation we had at that time
and i remember thinking
this is crazy like we are legitimately
yelling at each other we are about to
turn the car around on the freeway and
go home and not go to our vacation
over a cup of tea
and so finally
we just said all right hold on hold on
what are we really fighting about
and that was the beginning of realizing
my body sends me a signal it's making me
agitated i blanket interpret this as oh
i'm angry why am i angry oh because they
wasted time having this cup of tea
when in reality it was this way deeper
thing about respect
and i felt like
she wasn't understanding how important
it was to me
to have taken time off to go on this
vacation to spend money we were so poor
to spend money on a hotel so i wanted to
be there the second they would let us
into that room to feel like i was
getting the most out of my money and for
her she's like oh my god i'm finally
heard and understood that we're going on
vacation he's giving me some of his time
and so i'm going to start my day out
with a cup of tea and just bask in you
know going slow and not you know being
hard charging for a minute
but we weren't understanding each other
and so we had this huge blow up over the
tee so beginning to identify in real
time my body's telling me something i
don't want to shove it into this primary
basket of emotion i want to figure out
what's really going on
that's some egregious percentage of the
time it's somebody's triggered an
insecurity about something you're not
feeling respected you're not feeling
loved you're not feeling smart they make
you feel dumb make you feel poor
whatever you have your insecurities
around and when you can actually talk
about those insecurities now things
begin to unlock but it begins with that
process of i feel something in my body
what is it put a name to it make it as
nuanced as possible and then articulate
it out loud when you start doing that
enough all of a sudden you're able to
get to that very quickly and that will
change the game when you find even
something like a conversation you find
that your mind is wandering some of this
is just training yourself
to focus so we live in this eternally
distracted society where we're
constantly seeking those dopamine
rewards that you get from checking your
phone or whatever and you didn't list
that as one of the things that um is is
your problem but meditation is the
answer sort of regardless of what the
impetus is regardless of what it is that
you find yourself being pulled towards
whether it's the squirrel as you say or
something else
training yourself to be able to extend
the period of time where you're focusing
on one thing is going to be
extraordinarily helpful and it can be as
simple as just coming back to the breath
this does not need to be a grand
spiritual thing that you do though i
think there are huge benefits to
meditation on that side but
just
training your attention learning to
apply your attention to the thing that
you want to focus on is a skill all of
this stuff is a process and once you
understand that it is a process then it
becomes something that you can train and
so sitting in a
noisy room it doesn't even need to be a
choir room in fact it might be better
practice certainly as you get more
advanced to do it in a noisy room so
that you learn when something pulls your
attention that you have control of
bringing it back and in a meditative
practice that's focused around the
breath you would just come back to the
breath in a more
mindfulness approach you would use any
sensation that you can to come back to
this present moment it could be the
the noise that you heard of reminding
you that you're there in that room it
could be if your feet are starting to
tingle because of the way that you're
sitting it's you know feeling your back
against the couch whatever using
something that is
in that moment to remind yourself to be
present to be there not to let your
thoughts drift and you'll find that in
the beginning like man every three
seconds my mind is wandering i'm going
to something else and it may even take
you minutes before you even realize
that your attention is wandered
and in that moment you bring yourself
back to the breath you give yourself
some grace
you don't panic that you have let your
mind wander and you just keep doing that
and day after day you will find in the
beginning it's every three seconds and
then it's every 10 seconds and then you
might be able to stay focused on your
breath for 30 seconds one thing that i
did a lot in the beginning
is i would just count my breaths
and i would find in the beginning i
couldn't complete a single breath cycle
and stay focused on my breath for the
four parts of a breath cycle right the
inhale the inhale hold the exhale the
exhale hold those four parts
that's my meditation practice very
simple four part what they call box
breathing
and it's just box breathing those four
parts make up the four sides of the box
and
uh i couldn't make it through a single
breath without my mind wandering and
then i would get to the point where i
could do 10 breaths and then now i'd say
my record is probably somewhere around
16 or 17 breaths i don't think i've ever
made it to 20. um but that's a pretty
long time when you're breathing slowly i
would say it's
you know maybe two minutes something
like that it's a long time at least for
me to be able to keep my attention
totally uninterrupted on one thing how
do you deal with people that show
irritation when you speak
but don't address what their problem is
i love this one okay so here's what i do
i call that [ __ ] out in real time now i
don't call it out like yo [ __ ]
what are you doing i call it out like
hey let me know if i'm misreading but
you really seem frustrated it is so
scandalous nobody ever does that nobody
ever acknowledges the elephant in the
room people feel like
they can say something however they want
to say it and you're only going to be
able to comment on the actual words that
they say which is
that's some weird convention that just
isn't true and if you take the time to
say hey
totally i could be misreading this but
you seem frustrated
no no i'm not frustrated at all
you're coming across aggressive
and if you can help me understand why
because if there's something that i'm
doing or saying that's upsetting you i
want to understand it and if you're
saying that not as a gotcha but really
actually trying to understand it like
you're you're trying to disarm the
situation you are more than prepared to
point those two thumbs at you you're
more than prepared for you to actually
have done something that you didn't see
that might have upset that person that
might they might really have a
legitimate grief
and if you
come at it from that standpoint and
you're not trying to trick them trap
them you're just actually trying to
understand
that desire to understand and
when they realize there's nowhere to
hide because you're going to point out
the way that something is being
delivered and by the way i will throw
people a lifeline so when i say hey you
know i'm really just trying to
understand you seem upset frustrated
agitated
help me see because if i did something i
would want to address that and then if
they keep demonstrating that they're
angry but keep saying that they're not
then i would just say help me understand
the
the level of aggression that's coming
across now do you think i'm just
misinterpreting it whatever and so then
we go down that path now in a fantasy
land
there's somebody nearby that you can
actually pull in and so at impact theory
we always tell people don't go
have one of these arguments alone grab
another peer or in the case of a company
somebody that you report to to
essentially moderate the discussion so
you could say hey if you think i'm
misinterpreting the signal and that
there is no frustration or agitation
here i'm perfectly willing to
um be told that i'm just misreading the
situation and so then if it's like um
they're having a hard time
recognizing that they're being
frustrated if we were alone and there's
nobody there to moderate then i might
say something by way of a lifeline like
you know is it possible that when i said
this that that hit you the wrong way and
so you sort of pre-masticate the idea
for them maybe you have an insight that
they're unable to have and recognizing
that a lot of times people are angry but
they don't have the self-awareness to
understand what's happening so they're
getting frustrated they're angry about
something but they're not even sure why
or what they're angry with now
as somebody who's had that happen to me
where i'm like why the hell am i getting
sharp all of a sudden i have nothing but
empathy and compassion for whoever's
going through that so again i'm not
trying to trap them i don't want them to
look bad i'm going to help them navigate
their way out of this and i'm not trying
to win i'm not trying to prove anything
i'm trying to understand
and if you go into it trying to
understand
now the other person feels that you can
pull you can hand that olive branch or
you can say hey why don't we take a
minute
go our separate ways let's come back
rediscuss this and i'll try to see if i
can understand what i might have said
that upset you or to understand why i'm
misreading you or whatever and
if that's sincere and you're not just
trying to trick them then i think you'll
be shocked at how far that goes listen
and listen well because no truer words
are ever going to be unspoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever
it is that you decide you want to make
come true in your life you can
do that it is going to take an inhuman
amount of work you're going to have to
be prepared to break yourself in half
you are going to have to learn more than
anyone has ever learned you're going to
have to push yourself harder than anyone
has ever asked you to push yourself
before you're going to go way beyond
your breaking point you're going to run
until you vomit you're going to study
until you fall asleep you're going to
push and push and push and then you're
going to push some [ __ ] more and when
you hit the limit you're going to push
again beyond that you're going to force
yourself into an adaptation response and
why
because as malcolm x said
the future belongs to those who prepare
for it today
so if you don't put the work in today
if you don't do the unending back
breaking work of developing yourself
into something greater the world is
going to pass you by the people that are
going to own it are going to be the ones
that did that work and the one promise
that i can make you right now is that
somebody
somebody out there is out working
somebody right now
is doing the things that i'm saying
somebody right now
is doing the work of failing and getting
up and getting better and pushing
themselves and triggering that glorious
adaptation response that makes humans
the apex predator someone right now
they're putting in that work
and if you don't
the future is going to belong to them
and as martin luther king jr said
if you can't fly then run
if you can't run then walk if you can't
walk then crawl but whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward
it's not okay to make excuses it's not
gonna slow people down it's not okay to
ask the world to stop so that you can
step out front it's not okay to expect
little of yourself and
demand great rewards the only thing
that's okay is to be in line with the
way that the world really works and if
you want to be great you've got to
become capable of greatness you've got
to develop your skill set you've got to
take what you have now and if that's
crawling then [ __ ] crawl but you drag
yourself ever forward to a vision of
yourself that is so clear and so
specific that nothing could knock you
off your path because you my friend know
exactly where you're going you're
willing to pay whatever price it takes
to get there and no matter what anybody
says no matter how many [ __ ] hecklers
come for you no matter how many people
try to throw dirt on you try to stop
them try to knock you down no matter how
many [ __ ] people come for you at
night while you sleep you will rise and
you will keep pushing forward and you
will get better every day and no matter
how many times people chop at you knock
you down knock you off the path you will
get back on you will crawl till you can
walk you will walk till you run and then
you will run until you fly and that my
friends is the only path forward so if
you want a future that makes you happy
if you want a world that you're excited
about get your ass out there and earn it
quest nutrition and impact theory
were to go out of business tomorrow and
you were to lose all of your money and
material possessions what would you do
starting from scratch what are the first
things you would do in the first 90 days
oh god this is awesome okay so
what would i
do
okay step number one
deal mourn so honestly like i i would i
would allow myself a period of morning
and i would define that now i'm not
going to stand still during the morning
period but i think the reality is you
have to
okay who am i kidding i wouldn't do that
um i would defer my morning
i've been through something like this so
i know exactly what i would do i would
defer the morning and i would
immediately contact i would make a list
of all the people that were in the world
so unless i'm gonna i'm gonna assume for
a second that impact theory went out of
business um
for reasons other than that the industry
um i'll assume the industry hasn't
imploded that's a very weird way of
saying that um so i'm gonna go to the 10
people that i've already earned
credibility with that know what i'm
capable of that know how i think that
know my uh process that like me want to
be around me
and i'm gonna go offer my services to
them and i'm going to ask for either no
money if at all possible if i can my
wife and i can sleep on somebody's couch
or something like that um and in fact i
may send my wife to get a job that at
least makes some money so that we can
eat so that i can then begin going back
into the industry and delivering value i
think it's the area that i'm going to be
able to deliver the most value and i
would aim to get equity that's me so
that people understand look my business
may have failed but here's my vision
here's where i think i can add value i
would go in and i would have such a
freakish level of detail for what i'd be
able to do for their company and that i
would be asking for equity equity is a
big thing for me so um i wouldn't worry
so much about salary i would just make
sure that i was making enough to eat i
don't my ego isn't tied up in the house
so as much as i love the house and i
love all the worldly possessions um my
ego is tied up in my ability to learn
and my willingness to suffer like if you
really want to know what makes me an ego
maniac it's those things so why do i do
an 11 hour q and a because i know nobody
else can do it so and i just like every
minute that passes i'm getting more and
more arrogant about it and feeling great
and it's not like an ugly arrogance it's
like a fun arrogance of belief in myself
so
i'm gonna go to them with a scary
detailed plan about the way that i'm
going to help their company it is not
[ __ ] it's not fluff i will really be
breaking down how i can help their
company so that i can go in and crush
that meeting and say look
you know what just happened i will own
my mistakes i won't [ __ ] i'll say this
is exactly what happened this is what i
learned this is why i'm not going to
make those mistakes again and this is
what i think that i can do for your
company this is why i think that i
deserve equity and i'm just going to go
down that list someone is going to say
yes i would first go down
everything that i want to do in the film
industry and if i don't get any bites
there then i would immediately go down
food nutrition
and then
literally guaranteed one of those two
areas somebody would bring me on as an
equity partner because my pitch would be
ridiculous to the point where if all
they did was take the meeting their
business would be better for it so i
hold myself accountable to that to real
results i would be the best interview
they ever had i would be trying to give
away every idea for their company that i
have because i know ideas are a dime a
dozen and all that matters is execution
so they will be in the meeting thinking
oh my god if this is what he's willing
to do just to get like a meeting with us
what would he be willing to do if we
actually brought him on and started
paying him something so and again i
would throw my ask financially in the
dirt and i would say look i'll work at
this for a year um and if lisa's working
and we can afford to eat i would work
for free and i would say i'll do this
for a year i've no problem what i want
is the equity and then i would work my
way back up so
yeah i actually get excited answering
that question because if you can't face
the loss of all your material
possessions with excitement it means
that you don't believe in your abilities
and you need to spend time focused on
your abilities what i really really
enjoy in fact i ask this of everybody
not everybody i've asked this many many
many times of people coming into the
company there are two choices before you
choice number one
you help let's say five people and they
all know who you are they would credit
you with transforming their life at your
funeral they would say this man is their
woman is the reason that i have been
successful plain and simple i owe
everything to them they're crying and
it's like you touch their lives you
touch their families lives or
would you rather affect five million
people and none of them know who you are
now for me
it's not even tough choice i would
rather affect the five million people
and they have absolutely no idea who i
am at scale is all i care about that's
it i am obsessed with doing things at
scale
i've actually never taken the time to
reflect on why i like that so much but
scale is what matters to me really
helping a lot a lot a lot of people that
is the thing that i'm really driven by
i'm convinced that while virtually
everyone you're ever going to meet
they will tell you that they want to do
something great with their life they'll
tell you that they've got big dreams
they've got plans and they're going to
make it happen
but they can't take criticism
they're not willing to look at what
they're doing wrong they're not willing
to admit that everything is their fault
but it's just a frame of reference and
if they would change that frame of
reference it would change
everything
and as tim grover said
the only difference between feedback and
criticism is how you hear it
understanding the brain understanding
how we process data understanding the
way that ideas get into your mind and
cause a chain reaction of emotions
if you can't figure that out and rise
above it and not become a victim of your
emotions not become a victim to people
saying something that knock you off your
confidence that make you feel insecure
that actually [ __ ] your ability to
perform because of how
you have decided
to hear something
and that moment of awakening that
breakthrough that is the realization
that you decide
what to focus on you decide what to hear
and what to take away from something
somebody can assail you they can attack
you they can
victimize you
but it's a choice as to whether or not
you play the victim
as winston churchill said criticism may
not be agreeable but it's necessary
it fulfills the same function as pain in
the human body it calls attention to an
unhealthy state of things
in the pursuit of greatness people are
still trying to avoid pain
if you really want to do something if
you really want to become somebody
then you've got to run headlong into
pain you've got to be looking for those
things that make you suffer you've got
to seek out
the pain
you've got to seek out the things that
make you uncomfortable you've got to
want to hit that difficulty because it
is in those moments it is in that bit of
suffering it is in seeing what you are
not good at that is going to allow you
to become great and if you have to let
it fill you with rage to really
stand
in anguish
in order to force yourself to move
then stand in it
do whatever you need to do in order to
reach your goals and if that's the
motivation that you need then embrace it
and chase it
as tony robbins said the purpose of pain
is to move us into action
it's not to make us suffer
so in that anguish
in the
excruciating pain
find no suffering
see the joy in it welcome it like an old
friend and the day that you can welcome
your pain like an old friend because you
know like a friend it is taking you
where you need to go it is spurring you
into action it is pushing you to become
something and the process of rebirth my
friends
hurts
but whether you choose to suffer or not
is your choice
because remember tim's words
the only difference between feedback and
criticism is how you hear it the only
difference between pain and suffering
is how you frame it
so it's your choice
it's up to you how you're going to move
forward
but never
for one
second
forget
that it's a choice how do you deal with
pain do you reward yourself each day do
you seek instant gratification or do you
wait until you receive the pleasure you
actually want like achieving your
long-term goals
so it really depends on what the pain is
if it's an acute pain i force myself to
lean into it so like when i'm at the
dentist and it really hurts then i'll
actually open my mouth wider to make
sure that they get like absolutely no
subtle signal for me that i'm in pain uh
because i want them to do whatever the
hell they need to do no matter how much
it hurts and then i'm rewarding myself
in a self-congratulatory way for not
being a wuss and for dealing with the
pain when it's in service of something
that i actually want to do and achieve
when it's a longer term like slower pain
like just being ultra disciplined not
eating the things that i want to eat
oftentimes i'll focus on the results to
keep myself really excited about what
i'm doing so with diet living forever
optimizing my cognition looking good
naked i'll stop and think about those
things and think about having a
discipline that other people don't have
and that gets me excited i'll also
reframe it so if i'm really dieting hard
i know that i'm going to be hungry for
hours and hours and hours on end days
and weeks stacking up i will welcome the
hunger like an old friend and i will
literally say in my head welcome hunger
my old friend i am so glad that you're
here because it means that i'm
metabolizing fat so i do things like
that to really get my head in the right
place that i'm looking at something as
positive i'm looking at what it's
bringing me i'm focused on my goals i
know what i want
i'm focused on the identity of being the
kind of person that's willing to do that
and again it's self-congratulatory
because you're really stoked that you've
got the discipline and the ability to do
that stuff so learning how to be
self-congratulatory in a way that isn't
gross that doesn't make you an ego
maniac all that stuff i think is really
really important and people need to
learn to do that to have compassion have
love for yourself to really be stoked on
who you're becoming um i think is a
really really important thing you're the
average of the five people you spend the
most time with that's just true
and but now it's become so common to say
and it's like every instagram post that
i fear it's gonna lose its meaning who
are you spending time with because if
you're spending time with people like
you you're spending time with people
like me i'm i'm raising you up i'm just
not going to spend time with you
so it's like now if you get in a mix of
people like that who are like man we'd
love for you to raise up to this level
but if you don't it's fine but we're
just not going to spend time with you
all of a sudden that desire to belong to
something powerful that you can see is
going to lead you to your dreams and i
remember saying to my wife over and over
and over they are the surest path to my
success i don't know anything else i
just know if i can hang on to these guys
they're gonna make me better
and so that was through all the years of
being embarrassed and developing
actually massive anxiety because i was
always behind i was always the dumbest
person on the phone i was always the
dumbest person in the room and it was
like
was i going to be willing to emotionally
go through that to get great and most
people can't so here's the thing now
imagine i'm not the only person they
said hey this is a startup you can have
any job you want they i saw
12 people maybe more come and go over
the years they just couldn't emotionally
deal with it and so i remember thinking
to myself why is it that i'm able to do
this and the answer was i could
self-soothe faster than anyone else so i
would get kicked in the face and i would
do something really dumb i'd be called
an idiot told how stupid i was and then
i'd just be like all right i need to
re-center and that just became my
obsession i need to be able to
emotionally get back to complete neutral
so fast that you don't even see a
register on my face how'd you do it how
do you do that literally practicing so
remember the same time i'm reading about
the brain voraciously i'm reading about
people that understand human behavior
i'm getting into cognitive science
neuroscience like really going into it
so i'm reading all this stuff going whoa
we're just a chemical processing plant
there are physiological hooks into these
chemicals so hey if you're mad scared
whatever but you force yourself to laugh
out loud you will change your
neurochemical state and you literally
your experience is the neurochemistry so
i was like whoa so i could get i could
be in a situation where i'm being
berated or i legitimately mess up and it
costs money and it's like whoa that's on
me and it is nobody's bad but my own and
i realized that what most people do
their strategy is to deflect it it's
your fault it's not my fault yes so i
started thinking of this as a metaphor
people are throwing gold at me they're
throwing it really hard and i can put a
shield up and deflect it but then i lose
that piece of gold if i drop my shield
and just take the pain let it hit me in
the head then i bend down and go this
thing which is me being stupid there's a
lesson here and now i have this piece of
gold
but the whole thing is i have to be
defenseless so i have to own it i have
to take it i can't fight if someone is
like this to this day if our team is
like hey there's something we need to
point out to you i'll do this
i square up to it i want them to know
like hey i want to hear it i want to
know like i want to be literally
physically open i'm not going to close
down i'm going to do everything i can to
square off to open myself so that they
know i'm receptive to the criticism
right because that's the nugget of gold
what i know is it's going to hurt it's
going to sting but if i can emotionally
recenter so fast you don't even see that
i went through something now i can just
process how do i take this information
you've given me and get better 80 of my
time i spend focused on the beautiful
things that i want to create the amazing
things the the mission that i'm on how i
want to help other people right i talked
about goals being exciting to you
and honorable so they uplift you and
other people
and i try to spend as much time as i can
there
and that's gotten me through a lot of
difficult times to think about the
people i'm trying to serve to think
about the way that i'm going to help
people we end every team meeting at
impact theory with a connection to our
communities whether it's playing a video
of somebody who's changed their life or
reading a letter that somebody's written
us about how
the content that we create has moved
them forward in some meaningful way and
they're beautiful and it's amazing it
feels so good
but
there are times
where i'm so fatigued
there's a great quote by vince lombardi
fatigue
makes cowards of us all
and there are times where i'm so
fatigued
all the beautiful things in the world
are not enough to keep me going
and i'm just done i'm spent i'm in
i'm past the day david goggins 40
where he says when you think you're
broken and couldn't possibly go another
step you're only 40 of the way there
okay the beautiful things that get me
past that hurdle
but when you're actually 80 of the way
there 90 of the way there really close
to being fully spent
the thing that i lean on in that moment
is the dark side
the people that want me to fail
the people that are on my list
as i call it
there are people that have tried to
trip me up
that want to see me lose
that come at me go behind my back
whatever
and i put them on a list
and i never think about the list more
than 20 of the time because that's a
dark place to be
but when i'm really
tired
and i'm in danger of
cowardice
i think about those people
and it's an ugly energy
but damn
is it powerful
to say i'm not going to let them win
i will as david goggins says take their
souls
and it's really powerful
and it's one of those things that i
often get pushed back on because it is
ugly to say that i think about these
people and i think about destroying them
and beating them and outperforming them
in every way and dunking in their face
and doing better than them in life and
watching them
just get demolished by my performance
but it's motivating
and it works
now if you spend too much time there you
slide into bitterness you slide into
anger it's resentment it's all about
them
but man let me tell you
if you get that balance right 80 20
90 10
man it's
it's really profoundly powerful there is
a reason that evolution has given you
anger there's a reason that evolution
has given you rage there is a reason
that evolution has given you righteous
indignation
as gandhi said strength does not come
from physical capacity
it comes from an indomitable will
we're talking about a man that took on
an empire
and he did it not by his physical
prowess but instead by not being willing
to be bowed or broken and at the end of
the day
that is something each one of us
controls that is something that each one
of us can build into ourselves we decide
whether or not we can be broken we
decide how far we're willing to go and
at the end of the day how far you're
willing to go how indomitable your will
really is comes down to one
simple
thing
do you believe in what you're fighting
for
are the hard times something that you're
willing to push through to persevere to
get to the other side because you
believe to the core of your being and
what you're fighting for and that is
something we all have to define for
ourselves that is something we all have
to build into the very core of our being
but most people just
stumble through life they daydream
through life they don't have a plan they
don't have something specific that
they're aiming at and because of that
when they hit an obstacle because of
that
when they hit something that pushes back
against them when they hit
an equally obstinate force
they break they bow they crumble
because they don't have that thing
that they're willing to fight for they
don't have that burning ember inside of
them that is dictating everything that
they do and because of that they're
never going to be able to get on the
other side of that obstacle because of
that life is going to stop them because
of that
every time that they try to create
momentum in their life something stops
them but it's not the thing on the
outside that stops them it's the lack
of something on the inside and as
winston churchill said
if you're going through hell keep going
but the only way that you're going to be
able to persevere through that the only
reason that you're going to have that
thing inside of you that demands that
you keep going is if you believe in that
thing if you've built something up in
your life
that you'd be willing to die for
and you live for it
when you construct that at the center of
your soul then you're gonna have the
tenacity to push through then you will
see that you were not defined by your
physical prowess at that moment you will
understand
what gandhi was trying to say
that each and every one of us
will be made
by what we come to stand for each and
every one of us will be constructed
of our will
the things that we're able to do will be
defined by that so when you take the
time to build something
build the strength of conviction
that is what will see you through hell i
don't have natural talent in anything so
as a kid it was really doing things that
i got positive feedback from somebody so
my dad once told me that he thought that
i was better behind the camera than i
was in front of it and so for a lot of
years um i actually did think that i was
good at that and then i got slapped
around in film school and realized that
i didn't have any natural talent that
was an utterly heartbreaking moment and
that was me then having to come to
accept that i am like everyone i am i
was born hopelessly average
and my life has become a mission of
seeing what are the things that i care
enough about to become extraordinary and
then putting in the time and energy and
effort to actually become extraordinary
at that thing and i am utterly
astonished at
the breadth of things that you can
become good at if you're willing to
invest the time and energy so
my thing is don't limit yourself to what
you think you have a natural inclination
towards limit yourself to what makes you
feel more alive so it starts with an
interest ooh that is cool i'm interested
then by engagement it turns into a
fascination through the gaining of
mastery becomes a real passion like
that's the spectrum of things you want
to deal with not like am i good at it am
i not good at it for instance i'm
terrible at math and yet that was one of
the things that i had to get better at
i'm still terrible at high level math
but like functional math i got a lot
better at um that was really useful in
business
i certainly have absolutely no i have no
natural aptitude in that direction
so
but that's what my goals demanded one
day i will be over this cough
so that's the key is what are your goals
demanding of you and move in that
direction put the energy in
break it down practice it actually take
the time to get good and that's where
you're gonna see that you start to
believe in yourself and i think that
self-belief it exists on two planes
plane number one is just i choose to
believe i can learn anything and so
that's going to give you the willingness
to move forward because humans lead with
belief and the belief the only belief
you need to move forward
is that you can learn
and then the second part is confidence
comes from competence so actually
getting good at something i don't think
there's anything more intoxicating for a
human being than to get good at
something to not have been good at it
one day and then get good at it the next
is is just one of the most amazing
feelings that any human being can have
so i invite you all to go on that
journey i have a very hard and fast rule
that i use when it comes to this idea of
self-punishment now self-punishment can
be very useful but not when it gets to
the point where it is diminishing your
sense of self like what i see here when
you can't even let yourself believe that
you are worthy of improving getting
better and accomplishing things we're
now officially in what i'll call a death
spiral so the rule that i put in my life
is very simple and it allowed me to let
myself off the hook for things that i
had done in the past and it goes like
this
every human being
should only ever
do
and believe that which moves them
towards their goal now their goals
should be both exciting and honorable
meaning it should be exciting for you
but it should also not just serve you
but it should also serve other people so
no matter who you are no matter what
you've done
pursuing a goal that is honorable that
uplifts other people
why on earth would you not want yourself
to do that so if we can agree that
everybody should be pursuing
goals that are honorable and everybody
should only allow themselves to do and
believe
the things that propel them
down that path to actually achieving
that goal now it's not about you it's
just about common sense
for human society
for us as the human animal to get the
most out of this experience and to
contribute the most
then we have to put ourselves in a frame
of mind
that propels us down that path
there were so many times in my life
where
i
really believed that i was stupid or i
believed that i was unworthy or i
believed i needed to be punished for
something that i had done
and i would get in these loops of like
oh man i'm not good enough i'm never
going to achieve this and why am i even
bothering and
i realized that even though i would
ultimately get past it and be like look
just do it i would waste so much time
in this beating myself up cycle so i
created that rule that i was only going
to do and believe that which moved me
towards my goals so now it's like am i
good enough to do this am i worthy
enough to do this do i deserve to have
something positive happen in my life and
the answer is i'm going to believe that
yes i am good enough to pull this off
yes i am worthy of doing something like
this for two reasons one i'm only
pursuing things that are honorable in
the first place and two
such is the nature of the human animal
and the human experience that we should
all be getting ourselves in a mental
frame of reference that propels us
forward and so i just let myself off the
hook that even if
i deserve to be punished it wasn't going
to move me towards my goal it wasn't
going to help me contribute to myself
which by the way nobody should feel bad
about contributing to themselves but it
really wasn't going to help me
contribute to other people
and as long as i felt good about the
things that i was trying to do and
create it just made sense to let myself
off the hook so that i could take the
actions
that i needed to take in order to
help in order to contribute in order to
thrive
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing brendon burchard
motivation check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
ambition but too many of us back away
from it because it got made bad right i
was scared to have ambition because you
know what if you have ambition too big
for your britches
people start insulting you